we had a unit that was called special
status there's only two cells in there
two people in there it's where you put
your suicidal people people that can't
play well with others like it's you're
in there right I go in there to to do my
headcount make sure everyone's in there
and I look up on the ledge and there's
like a fully formed like it looks like a
baked potato and I'm looking a little
bit closer and on the wall you see like
little brown like blotches well what had
happened was this guy had taken human
and molded it into what looked like
a baked potato and the only thing I can
think of is he somehow got a racket and
started whing this potato
against the wall it ain't a potato stop
calling a potato dude it's a poop
potato the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
today